en la víspera del super domingo
electoral andino tres países de américa
latina celebran este domingo sus
llamados a las urnas a la sombra de la
pandemia de kobe 19 ecuador se encuentra
fracturado en la segunda vuelta de los
comicios los ecuatorianos deben decidir
entre el neoliberalismo de guillermo
lasso o el retorno al socialismo de
andrés araujo el candidato al correísmo
para suceder al presidente lenin moreno
ambos prometen la superación de la grave
crisis económica de una nación con
fuertes divisiones políticas ideológicas
y sociales donde el / voto indígena que
representa entre el 7 y el 10 por ciento
tres censo nacional puede ser la llave
del triunfo electoral a mí me gusta las
elecciones para nombrar un mejor ecuador
tener algo pero una elección que se
anuncia muy indecisa y el preludio de ir
a la segunda vuelta en los comicios más
abiertos de la historia en un país donde
el carisma del candidato prevalece sobre
las ideologías 18 candidatos
presidenciales debate en la primera
jornada electoral peruana con 6
liderando las encuestas pero sin que
ninguno supere el 13 por ciento de
intención de voto para resolver la
inestabilidad institucional crónica la
crisis
o me caí la emergencia sanitaria en
medio de un desencanto generalizado con
la clase política peruana
el fujimorismo está aprovechando la
ventana de oportunidad pero los
escándalos de corrupción de su líder
keiko fujimori genera el rechazo entre
el electorado
quizá nada
[Música]
bolivia elige los gobernadores en
segunda vuelta en cuatro de sus nueve
departamentos donde el movimiento al
socialismo del ex presidente evo morales
busca el control de las principales
gobernaciones para hacerse con la
soberanía de la mayor parte del país
adicional al ejecutivo que ostenta a su
aliado luís arte